- As a closeted gay boy in high school,
it was my dream to try Jessica
Simpson's edible makeup line.
This is literally the most
exciting moment of my life,
I've been waiting for years to do this
and I can't even believe
I can do this right now!
(rhythmic music)
- Not to toot my own horn or anything,
but I had like a pop
culture/celebrity blog when I was 12.
- Am I a pop culture junkie?
I think to the outsider I would be,
I've been working at
Buzzfeed for almost 10 years,
so I've been doing this
for a really long time.
- I was a big Keeping Up
with the Kardashians fan,
back in like 2007/2008.
- I did own three Von Dutch hats.
- Oh!
- And I bought them because
Britney Spears wore them.
- George Foreman Grill.
Boom.
That's the number one celebrity product.
- Like I just love all things
celebrity and pop culture.
(rhythmic music)
- We're gonna have Pimp Juice?
Got some good old Pimp Juice.
- Oh, Pimp Juice!
- Pimp Juice is iconic.
I mean, it's Nelly,
Nellyville, Hot in Herrre.
♫ Hot in--
- Is this gonna make me hot?
- Oh yeah.
- I like the smell.
- I mean, it smells exactly
like Red Bull pretty much.
- It does.
(soda can opening)
- Oh nice!
- No!
- Yes!
- Oh my god!
(laughing)
- What?
- Sip, sip!
(rhythmic music)
- That is so, oh!
- Letitloose.com.
Wonder if that domain still exists.
(clicking)
(buzzer buzzing)
- I was expecting
carbonation, but it's not.
- I just don't get why
they didn't carbonate it.
- Right.
- Like it makes no sense.
- Because I'm garbage I don't hate it.
- Honestly this is really good.
(intense music)
- [Brunette Man] This is intimidating.
- Oh, what is this?
- Huh.
(coughing)
- Why does it look like cat food?
- So it's pudding, wait,
Stallone, oh my God, okay.
- Sylvester, what are you up to?
- It's truly delicious,
satisfying, and guilt free.
- Who would want to eat
anything out of this can?
- This is, oh my--
- Oh!
- The consistency is like,
I thought it was gonna,
you gotta really pierce it,
it's got a little skin.
(coughing)
- It just doesn't look like
people should be eating this.
- Are we gonna get sick or
are we just gonna get swoll?
- Oh gosh, okay.
- There's some chalkiness.
- It made my mouth instantly dry.
- Post workout pudding sesh, yeah!
Everyone grab your spoons.
- Mmm!
- Pimp Juice solves all of our problems.
- Oh my God, this is a dream come true!
Jessica Simpson's edible makeup line.
- Sexy girls have dessert?
Oh my goodness.
- Mmm.
- Who was responsible for this?
- Are you a dessert girl?
Dessert girls aren't afraid to heat it up,
shake it up, be a flirt, put
it out there and flaunt it.
- Oh, ugh.
(coughing)
- Wait, it doesn't smell that good.
- Oh yes, look at the shimmer.
(rhythmic music)
- Can we do--
- I'm like, "I want this
"all over my body."
- No!
- Oh moisturizing, decadent.
- I feel like I did this all wrong.
(laughing)
Oh snap!
Now it looks like I've
got some skin issues.
- So this is like sex cream.
(record scratching)
- Right?
- This is sex cream.
Okay, wait, Jessica Simpson
made sex cream in 2004.
- Hey I'm taking advantage
this is my dream come true.
This is like 16 year old gay
me'd be freaking out right now.
- Yo, 2004 was a crazy time!
- [Producer] Which product was the best?
- Jessica Simpson by far,
they need to start making this again.
- The only product I would
see myself using ever again
would probably be Pimp Juice.
- I'm gonna go with Pimp Juice.
- Pimp Juice is good too.
- Delicious!
- I gotta say I was a
fan of the Pimp Juice.
- I was a fan of the Pimp Juice, too.
- I think the Pimp Juice is the winner.
- Hey, call me a sucker,
but if it's on TV,
I wanna buy it, and so
I'm gonna buy anything
that a celeb--
- Case in point.
You are the case in point.
And you smell great.
- I smell so good right now, it's crazy!
- We're good to go.
(rhythmic music)